what frustrates you about screenwriting
with screenwriting I frustrated mostly
but my own limitations ah you know every
writer i think is in their own head and
you end up just there's rabbit holes you
always going down the things that you're
interested in that aren't very broad and
i wish i could think more broadly as a
writer i wish i was interested in more
things and i wish you know you don't
often you look back at your work and you
see what you what you're obsessed that
what ideas or what themes you tend to
recur on it's not intentional at all and
I'm you're always stuck in the same
loops and I wish I could break out of
those more but yeah and the time thing
of course always not enough time to
spend writing so
you